catherine hill épidémiologiste bonsoir
catherine hill merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors les
résultats sont bons sur le plan
sanitaire nous expliquer le premier
ministre ajoutant évidemment qu'on ne
pouvait pas courir le risque de la
désinvolture que le virus était encore
présent sur le territoire
il n'empêche à partir de deux joints la
liberté va devenir la règle et
l'interdiction deviendra l'exception
votre réaction à ce diagnostic catherine
il vient à la fois tout le monde est
content si on avance tout va mieux mais
quand même le virus continue à circuler
et ça c'est quand même une souci donc
plus de gens vont rencontrer plus de
gens dont qu'ils augmentent leurs
chances d'être infectés c'est ça le
problème
il va vouloir surveiller de très près
est ce que je déplore c'est qu'on a
n'est pas toujours pas une stratégie de
tests très très large
en fait il faudrait tester beaucoup plus
largement que ce qui est prévu de faire
on ne teste que les gens qui sont
symptomatiques et leurs contacts
mais il ya beaucoup de contamination qui
sont qui viennent de gens qui sont
asymptomatiques c'est cela qu'il faut
trouver pour te virus continue à
circuler c'est bien ça le problème
à partir du moment catherine hill où on
n'a pas les tests que vous appelez de
vos voeux est ce que vous trouvez que
cette accélération dans le déconfinement
annoncée par le premier ministre va
peut-être un peu trop vite ou c'était la
bonne décision à prendre aujourd'hui
selon vous moi je pense qu'on veut faire
faire autrement
sinon on va vers une catastrophe
économique qui est encore bien plus
embêtant donc voilà il faut il faut bien
avancer
donc on peut pas faire autrement mais il
faut que tout le monde continue à faire
très très attention
les gens continuent à se promener dans
paris je pars je marchais aujourd'hui il
ya la moitié qui n'a pas de masque donc
ça c'est vraiment un problème
si vous êtes un peu longtemps avec des
gens qui se savent pas contaminés et
qu'il crache du virus au tour ne vous
êtes un risque de tomber malade c'est
quand même embêtant
donc il faut que tout le monde porte un
masque pour que ceux qui sont positifs
et qu'ils ne savent pas porte un masque
c'est sale c'est ça la règle est
pourtant sauf erreur de ma part pas
vraiment de mots alors évidemment sur
les gestes barrières on
général mais toujours pas d'obligation
de porter de masque un exigé par le
premier ministre c'est peut-être que ce
qu'il aurait dû faire selon vous non
obligation non mais être clair en disant
quand vous êtes dehors quand vous êtes
dans une boutique maintenant tout le
monde a compris qu'il valait porter un
masque mezzo aussi parce que vous allez
croiser des gens et puis vous allez
monter dans l'autobus vous avez oublié
de mettre votre masque il faut la voir
tout le temps c'est sale c'est ça le
truc c'est pas une option
il faut que ça soit vraiment intégré on
vient dans la rue là dans les images on
vous montre et on voit déjà avec des
basques c'est bien mais il y en a
beaucoup qui n'en n'ont pas non plus
pignon sur sous le manteau ou autour du
cou dans leur poche
je vous avais une serveuse veille à
quelques jours avec effectivement les
des images de ce canal saint-martin
rempli de monde ça vous faisait voilà un
petit peu frémir aujourd'hui les parcs
et jardins vont rouvrir notamment dans
la capitale qui est toujours en zone
orange à la demande d'ailleurs de la
maire de paris la règle des 100 km et
bien c'est fini également le plus grand
danger il vient de là au contraire des
rassemblements qu'évoquer edouard
philippe
le danger vient de partout selon vous
aujourd'hui il ya deux choses qui font
le danger la première chose c'est
combien de gens se promènent en ile de
france
aujourd'hui en étant positif et on ne
sachant pas en étant contaminants et on
ne sachant pas on sait pas si c'est un
sur mille ou un sur dix mille c'est
quand même embêtant
et la deuxième chose il faut si on
connaissait ça on pourrait réfléchir à
combien de gens différents on a croisé
dans la journée donc puis vous croisez
le jean et plus il ya de gens
contaminants plus vous avez de chance
tomber malade
c'est très simple à une arithmétique
très simple en fait
alors qu'après mille le virus circule
toujours ça tout le monde est d'accord
pour le dire il n'empêche l'épidémie
semble marquer
le pas les médecins ne sont pas toujours
d'accord l'un des premiers c'est didier
raoul qui disait voilà à prédire que
l'épidémie partirait avec les beaux
jours que c'était saisonniers j'espère
que je relate bien c'est trop avec le
virus continue à circuler
est ce que vous vous pouvez envisager
aujourd'hui finalement qu'il n'y aura
pas de deuxième vague et que ce virus
est en train par bonheur peut-être de
disparaître justement avec la belle
saison est ce que vous l'envisagez vous
j'aimerais bien pouvoir l'envisager mais
je surveille les indicateurs et des
indicateurs les tout diminuer les
hospitalisations les admission en
réanimation et nombre de morts ya baissé
régulièrement ça mais c'est d'abord vite
au moment au début du conflit manqué
ensuite plus lentement et maintenant
encore plus lentement tellement que c'en
est arrivé quelque chose d'un peu
constant et donc c'est difficile de dire
si ça va recommencer à augmenter ou
rester un haut niveau c'est ou bien
diminué c'est vraiment impossible de
prévoir mais ce que je déplore c'est
qu'on ne fasse pas des tests massivement
comme amour and par exemple où il ya le
virus continue ou a réapparu
ils ont décidé qu'ils allaient tester
toute la population et ils vont tester
toute la population en faisant des tests
groupe et c'est à dire en mettant les
prélèvements de 20 personnes dans le
même tube pour regarder s'il ya du virus
dans l'ensemble de ses vins prélèvements
si c'est négatif ces 20 personnes sont
présumées négative
donc on peut tester beaucoup plus de
gens avec ce système mais ici on parle
pas du tout de tester des gens qui ne
sont pas symptomatique sauf des contacts
de personnes symptomatique et ça c'est
un problème
merci en tout cas catherine hill
épidémiologiste d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rtl france